voilà nous sommes à la ferté macé c'est
le début du printemps de la chanson dans
l'orne
reprenez vous attend d'eux c'est là où
ça vous retrouvera sabine tout à l'heure
à cherbourg mais pour l'instant c'est le
groupe pas du tout elle vit ce qui
arrive avec son matériel on va l'essayer
saluons les radios elvis et on est dans
là où ça bouge au loin les pires amis
quand je regarde le programme du
printemps de la chanson jusqu'au 26 mars
et c'est la onzième édition je me dis
que vous avez une belle affiche ça fait
comme une espèce de deux axes ce
festival qui qui d'année en année sept
ans dans tout le département
oui c'est bien ça et puis là cette année
c'est particulièrement une vague parce
qu'on reçoit izia et la vague c'est le
nom de son dernier album sur les
allemands en france est évoquée via
jouera le 22 mars au forum de flers
alors hubert-félix thiéfaine cd complet
ça s'est très très bien passé on va
aller dire ses amis comme au concert
mais reste un concert aussi ce week-end
qui a lieu demain
oui à tourouvre donc c'est un double
plateau organisé grâce au festival
international de la chanson de granby
c'est michel robichaud un jeune auteur
compositeur interprète canadien et le
groupe bon débarrasser du néo trad
on en a pour tous les goûts et c'est à
20h30 à la salle une ambiance très très
québécoise pour nous
on va rencontrer radio elvis un groupe
déjà présenté dans là où ça bouge et qui
sortira son premier album le 1er avril
après deux ans de tournée on retrouve ce
que vous êtes quand même fait un album
qui dès il arrive après presque deux ans
de tournée donc donc c'est pas c'est pas
rien de composer des morceaux contourner
d'avoir déjà un bagage à mon arrivée en
studio il est issu de cette énergie là
comme là ce soir
ici à la ferté macé tous ces concerts
vous ont nourri pour l'écriture
moi j'aimerais vraiment en plus et on
est parti nous le principal était
d'enregistrer le tout la base de toute
la base de toutes les chansons
conditions live en studio on essayait de
faire voler le plus large possible
et pour nous c'est le principal la scène
française c'est ça qui nous qui nous
fait vivre aujourd'hui et dans tous les
sens du terme ça me fait vraiment des
sangsues et bien voilà radio elle vit
sur scène c'est ce soir à la ferté macé
le nouvel album vous avez compris va
arriver très très vite dans la rue 1er
avril donc c'est parfait
et puis nos va retrouver sabine daniel
qui te côté de cherbourg pour fêter le
printemps aussi sabine à cherbourg le
bras temps c'est vite dit quand même à
brac
même si aujourd'hui est un bon effet
très beau mais ça c'est normal c'est
parce que c'est le début du festival
spring normandie unifiée elle existe
aussi pour spring oui effectivement ce
festival est organisé par la plateforme
de pôle cirque en normandie qui donc
existe depuis le début de l'année et
puis cette plate forme donc propose des
spectacles de cirque à elbeuf puisque
c'est en partenariat et c'est avec le
certaines d'elbeuf que nous avons monté
cette plateforme 15 spectacles sont
cette année à la fiche du festival du
cirque spring on arrive à travailler à
la fois sûr qu'on peut appeler des
spectacles émergents ou des premiers les
premiers spectacles comme celui du
groupe becquerels et puis aussi
d'accueillir des artistes confirmés
puisqu'on on propose une traversée dans
l'oeuvre de fja ménard ce qui est
exceptionnel et ya qu une dimension de
festivals qui permet au public de
de découvrir tous les aspects
historiques d'une avant on va retrouver
je crois les artistes de becquerels
là quatre agrès de cirque un du fils du
mât chinois de la bascule et de la corde
comment vous définiriez ce spectacle que
vous allez donner sommes direction si je
reprends en fait les termes d'un jeune
garçon qui est venu voir le spectacle à
creil peut-être de la faïencerie à
quelques jours il a dit que c'était
comme une forme de fresque épique et
humaine qui retrace un peu toute
l'histoire de l'humanité
c'est une belle ambition donc à voir
absolument becquerels ces samedi 12 à
20h30
ici au théâtre à l'italienne de
cherbourg
ces descentes hasard et pour terminer
demain soir art plume à saint lô la
tchoucrav employés à partie et me fire
un groupe du cotentin en concert